we continue to follow the other big
story of the night's horses telling us
and police just confirming two children
were shot in the Northwest Valley one of
those children with life-threatening
injuries Metro telling us has happened
95 in Durango that's where we find eight
news now reporter Madison Kimbrough with
the latest
yeah still a very active scene as you're
about to see as Metro confirmed that a
boy and girl were shot here in the
street in this Northwest Valley
neighborhood near Durango and Elkhorn
Metro Police received multiple calls
just before four this afternoon about a
shooting once police arrived at the
residence here on Jamie Lee Avenue they
found that the two kids had already left
and were driven by families to
Centennial hospital which is about a
half a mile from the home they then were
transported to
UMC trauma police say one of the victims
has life-threatening injuries while the
other has non-life-threatening injuries
and currently Metro is assessing video
footage to identify the suspect in the
vehicle who did this it's still unclear
who was involved and what led up to this
shooting but keep it here on 8 news now
as we plan to talk to Residents in this
neighborhood about what they saw or what
they heard we will bring that to you in
the latest possible details sending it
back to you